ce soir les enfants
bruce mois
nous sommes arrivés nounours tu ne
descend pas rendre visite à des amis je
veux patron bon le châle ou aimons le
shell la fois l' as
voilà pour les chats
l'eau
j'avais des cendres voix
nicolas pas preneur
je vais leur dire on soit j'ouvre la
fenêtre centre son bruit je crois qu'ils
ont être tous deux surpris
si je dois me charme
je jouais
avec
jean tronc de ta part
dauchot
[Musique]
j'écris papa nicolas et moi j'écris très
bien aussi
regardez la sq étaient créés bien je
sais écrire toutes les notes de musique
dont sol rue
oui ni non les petits
nous avons assez travaillé aujourd'hui
qui veut danser avec moi et moi
moi je vais dans une aujourd'hui avec
une petite série
yannick a dit je vais vous montrer moins
garder pour un peu parce qu'on pût
moines en eau la manne et surtout tenons
nous bien d'accord on va tourner à
lattes se frotter mais gentiment sans
tout ce qu'il a à 2
on va s'arrêter à dire de l'autre voter
un move est une promenade
g cham et j'ai un ami à moi si c'est ça
vous plaît tant mes enfants venez pavesi
un petit tour taxis je vous prie et
c'est réussi
nous maintenons chantons tous en quarts
en avant les bons danseurs
c'est pas possible tu d'hépatite château
où le joueur aux hausses étaient de
petits garnements attendait un peu cela
vaut du petit farceur bien notre boulot
et viale bonne nuit les petits la jette
un oeil sommes venus jardine houston
unibal à tort bien apprenez venue des
enfants
allez vite vous coucher et n'oubliez pas
de faire votre toilette et de bien vous
laver les dents à voici nounours
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tu as des puces tu te
grattes ces petits cocos je ne danserai
plus jamais avec je suis sûr du
contraire nounours je peux le menton sur
pas trop alors en route
bonne nuit les enfants
fait pour eux
e
[Musique]